bonsoir philippe rogué merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous lambda epsilon
différents types de variantes plus ou
moins inquiétant on sourirait un des
noms donnés si ce n'était pas aussi
grave on a envie de vous poser une
question toute simple la question que
tout le monde se pose quand est-ce que
ça va s'arrêter
eh bien ça s'arrêtera quand on aura à
juguler cette épidémie c'est à dire que
quand tu es le virus ne circulera pas ou
presque pas et dans ce cas là
effectivement les mutations vont
diminuer ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'elle
s'arrêtera complètement
on l'a bien vu pour la grippe ou pour
certains autres virus donc ça peut
rester ce qu'on appelle endémique en
tout cas pour l'instant on en est loin
de ça c'est très épidémique et et
variant comme c'était prévu par beaucoup
à meinier par d'autres s'accumulent et
s'aggravent les uns les autres
l'an dernier donne donc classé à suivre
par l'om est ce ça veut dire quoi
concrètement comment on décide de
classer à suivre invariants et de classe
et inquiétant un autre ce n'est pas
facile
d'abord il faut le retrouver dans
plusieurs endroits en même temps il faut
avoir du séquençage notamment qui permet
de le détecter très rapidement ce qui
nous manque totalement en france et puis
ensuite il faut faire des corrélations
entre le nombre de cas avec ce variant
et puis l'a transmise à 7 soit transmise
pas ce qu'on appelle le r de
transmission le taux de transmission
et puis on regarde aussi les entrées
dans les hôpitaux on regarde les
symptômes et on regarde la mortalité
avec ça on compare plusieurs pays
on arrive à avoir une idée si ce variant
d'avoir ci se développe et s'il est
dangereux par exemple variant et simone
est très dangereux mais pour l'instant
il se développe pas il ya à peu près de
5% des cas en californie donc ce n'est
pas un danger majeur
exelon vous parlez de séquençage 77000
séquençage en france alors que le
royaume uni
on a pratiqué près de 600 milles depuis
le temps qu'on en parle vous êtes l'un
des chantres de cette méthode
pourquoi ce retard français persistant
ce retard est pour moi idéologique il y
à une opposition d'un certain nombre de
virologues notamment membre du conseil
scientifique qui refuse de penser qu'il
ya autre chose que la protéine spike et
de quelques mutations qui détecte il ya
d'ailleurs très difficilement par pcr et
nous les généticiens on pense que je
sais quand c'est l'ensemble du génome
parce que invariants lambda une si bonne
et bien c'est pas simplement de trois
mutations c'est tout un ensemble et
c'est ça que lui donnent ses
caractéristiques particulièrement
dangereuse justement ces mutations
quelle est la rapidité de ces mutations
du duc ovi 19 ans on a le sentiment vous
allez peut être me corriger si je me
trompe que plus ça va plus les variants
se développe nombreux et rapidement
est ce que c'est vrai hong et une raison
à ça c'est que par rapport à la souche
chinoise d'origine il s'agit d'une
accumulation de mutation par exemple
varie anglais c'était 18 mutation le
variant 10 indiens de delta ses quinze
habitations et en fait les premières
mutations qui sont apparus ne reprenais
rien du tout comme elle comme les faits
et puis progressivement il y en a
certaines qui vont avoir un effet nous
on appelle synergies que c'est à dire
qu'elles vont alors entraîné tout un tas
de caractéristiques qui rendent dans le
virus plus contagieux voir une 1 re
peut-on envisager l'hypothèse heureuse
d'ailleurs d'un nombre limité de
mutation qui conduirait le
le virus à une impasse enfin ça c'est
une hypothèse défendue par de plusieurs
virologue français qui pour l'instant ne
s'est pas passé il savait si on
ressemble pas à une mouche ou un
diplodocus c'est que notre génome à à
des ressources très importantes je
dirais infinie de transformation et donc
les virus existent depuis des milliards
d'années ont montré leur capacité à se
transformer donc moi je ne crois pas que
le virus du cornât va brutalement
s'arrêter d'être imaginatif
au contraire ça va continuer on ne
rassurait pas comme d'habitude mais bon
on vous interdit pas pour être rassurés
on veut bénéficier votre vos
connaissances précieuses
al'inverse à ce que ça peut aller encore
plus loin et plus fort est arrivé a
vraiment eu vingt huit ans extrêmement
dangereux encore plus meurtrier toujours
plus meurtriers ce que c'est une
hypothèse que vous envisagez également
c'est une hypothèse que toujours
plausible mais pour l'instant c'est pas
ce qui arrive puisque c'est ces variants
n'entraîne pas de résistance en vie
réelle contre contre les vaccins
notamment les vaccins et rennes je pense
qu'aujourd'hui à la meilleure chose à
faire est de se faire vacciner
massivement car si on diminue la
distribution diminue aussi les capacités
de changements de limitation de ces
virus et bien entendu le risque de se
retrouver malade est encore plus de
d'être très malade et à l'hôpital voir
de vos pays
craignez-vous justement par rapport à
cette vaccination qu'un jour un mutant
soit beaucoup plus fort et que le vaccin
n'est plus aucune efficacité
pour l'instant c'est pas ce qui est
arrivé est donc on peut espérer qu'on
aura juguler l'épidémie avant que ça
arrive mais n'oublions pas quand même
que
des fabricants sont en train de
réfléchir à une deuxième voire troisième
génération de vaccins ce qui risque de
nous arriver
pour l'élan vacciner comme moi c'est
d'avoir une troisième dose à la fin de
l'année c'est ce qui est préparé en
israël en angleterre et aux états unis
encore faut-il que cette troisième d'eau
soit un peu transformés pour permettre
de résister aux variants présent et
peut-être même le futur
cet effet de forgan quelque chose qu'on
entend ici ou là dans la rue et
évidemment pas par des généticiens mais
quand on dit voilà quand on voit ces
vexe ces variants qui se propage on se
dit que ça ne peut que être sorti d'un
laboratoire qu'est ce que vous répondez
à ce genre de phrases ont chois faire
attention aux discussions
conspirationnistes il ya tout un débat
scientifique là dessus comment se
fait-il que cette zone au c'est à dire
cette infection chez des animaux soient
passés à l'homme est encore un article
aujourd'hui là-dessus qui semble
expliquer ce qui a pu arriver
je pense personnellement que l'hypothèse
la plus probable c'est que c'est pas ce
soit pas un accident de laboratoire mais
que c'est une une transformation à
partir de gens qui ont manipulé manger
rendu des animaux sauvages
ce qui n'aurait dû jamais dû faire merci
philippe ah non pas stéphane philippe
froguel d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes un chercheur et
généticiens merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous